[Musique]
allez-y vous êtes vous êtes l'un des
rares humoristes que vous avez dit
direct c'est un petit pas d'imitation
vous avez 8 et didier deschamps la
perfection et le plus récemment karine
le marchand
à l'aller nous faire les chroniqueurs on
doit trouver de qui il s'agit vous allez
venir à côté un corps et c'est parti
regardez tout d'abord cet extrait c'est
parti c'est pas attention non plus à
rien on voit des 510 dit non
en fait
pour dire
[Applaudissements]
ça tombe bien j'avais un petit peu froid
voilà
elle s'est improvisée de la sierra même
si la danse à coller la cave de gad
elmaleh qu'exceptionnelle gad aussi à
mettre à côté moi allez va digérer ce
que je peux faire un gros bisou à
ludovic berrien bien sûr une radio qui
nous regardent wael ludovic brave nous
est tout à fait exceptionnelle et bravo
à alice également commence doucement tu
vois ça ratisse tony romo stroke je fais
des retournés tête et/ou à huawei fédé
retourné de tête mais est ce que ça avec
les perruques ou sans les perruques avec
un avec fait comme c'est facile avec les
plus grands vins non même avec les
paires utile on peut paraître un peu
morini bosc
c'est ma mamie j'aime bien
mais ça se voit c'est dans les détails
ça suffit ça c'est qu'ils sont basses et
gilou ces kiss avec ses lots
[Applaudissements]
h le temps plus difficiles cela elle va
subir il est subtile ok nathan fake je
m'assieds suit la base
géraldine géraldine ces vilains oui je
vous ai offert un livre ni le prendre
voilà c'est celui ci ou faisaient voile
à feuilleter
oui nous sommes et bien vous lisez des
trucs non pas l'une a rien dedans n'y a
rien c'est une autobiographie de la
carrière de leurs maux
même si l' étude jalel ahmed
[Applaudissements]
je me remets l'accord mais je n'en fais
je dis parce que comédien